- [Voiceover] So I've copied
and pasted this question
from the exercises on Khan Academy.
It says, "Sort the following expressions
"from least to greatest
based on the coordinates
"of the rectangle below."
So we need to figure out
would y, z and x are.
Then we assort them.
So let's first look at,
well let's look at y.
And this is a little bit counter intuitive
because they're using the variable y
to represent the x-coordinate,
to represent the x
coordinate of this point.
So let's see if we can figure out
what the x-coordinate of this point is.
Well it's a rectangle.
The x-coordinate of this
point right over here,
it's going to be the same as
the x-coordinate of this point.
They sit on the same vertical line
the way that it is drawn.
So if this has an
x-coordinate of x equals four,
then this is going to have
an x-coordinate of four.
And now we use a variable
y for the x-coordinate
which is a little strange
but this is going to be
the point four comma seven.
So y is equal to four.
Now let's see what we
can figure out about z.
Well, z is the y coordinate for,
let me use another color here,
z is the y coordinate for this point.
Now, what other point has
the same y-coordinate?
Well, it's going to be at the same level,
I guess you could say,
in the vertical direction.
It's going to sit on the
same horizontal line.
So it's going to have the same
y-coordinate as this point.
Now this point has a
y-coordinate of three.
So this point, it's y-coordinate
is going to be three
or we could say that z is equal to three.
So this is going to be equal to three.
And then last but not least,
we need to figure out what x is.
And x is the x-coordinate.
Let me do this in another color.
X is the x-coordinate for this point.
Well, this x-coordinate is
going to be the same thing
as the x-coordinate for this point up here
which is equal to two.
They sit on the same vertical line.
They both sit on the line,
x equals two.
And so x is going to be two.
It is the x-coordinate and
it's also the variable x.
So this is going to be two.
So if we want to sort them
from least to greatest,
x is the least.
Then we would go, it's
actually the exact opposite
of what we have here.
The x then z, then y.
Two then three, then four.
So actually, let me get the exercise out
and just check our answer.
So x is the least
then z is in the middle
and then y is the largest.
We can check our answer.
We got it right.